Hey, buddy.
Nice ass.
BOW!
You gotta be kidding me.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me.
Ohhh, you gotta be kidding me.
You get back here, you bitch.
YOU GET BACK HERE YOU BITCH!
You...you're gonna die tonight.
You, and your taut chest and your... Lovely butt
You look good sailor! SMACK!
Good Job Let's go.
Oh what's that over there!
♫(rock music)♫
Ahh kids?
Aren't you a little concerned about this?
PUT YOUR ARMS IN THE AIR!
WAVE EM LIKE YOU JUST DUN CARE!
♫(dancy music)♫
Captain on deck! All Hail....
Nice ass there, ooh nice face too...
How 'bout you, do you have a taut buttocks?
SMMACK! Good job.
UUrrrrrr kay.. Normal human...
Ohh God... Normal human...
Normal everyday human!!
Ooohh! Normal! Normal! Normal! Normal!
I'M NORMAL!
I'M NORMAL!!
Sorry I'm normal!
(roaring)
Normal!
Normal!!
NORMAL!
I do not want!
To grope this shark can!
[Erotic Music]
Puuurrrrr...
Fe-EGH! OOHH NO!
NURRH NOH NOH NOH NOH NOH!!
NO NO! Just a normal... Human being...
Grinding on...
Shark tank....
Errgh.. Oh No... Ooh No!
Oh no... Oh no....
NO!! NOOO!.........
[LAUGHS EXCITEDLY]
[INDECIPHERABLE BLUBBERING]
[MARK LAUGHS]
I just BEANED my kid in the back of the head
with a gallon of milk..
perfectly normal dad stuff!
I know you have camouflage,
but I didn't know it was THAT good!
(Mark's evil laugh)
♫(dramatic funeral music)♫
"Would you care for a dance?"
[INDECIPHERABLE BLUBBERING]
I'm gonna lose my MIIIIIIIIIIIIIINNNNND!
Did I wanna go over there?
DID I WANNA GO OVER THERE?
How about NO?
Raise arm! Raise arm!
NOOOO F@% F$£µù% F$£µù% F$£µù%
Come.. COME on!!
YOUMOTHERF-----
GRAAAAAB IT!
MOOOOVE IT!!
Okay, thank you for doin' that
Pump it up!... oh yeah! You like how I puuump it baby?
You like how I puuump this fish?!
Uahhhh ~~ F#%§$&~~
If I could juuuuuuust get up heeere
F...@@@ $3%%^
JUST PULL IT!
♫(drums)♫
Oh get the damn fruit!
NO!!!!!!!!!
Rewind! That never happened!
Rewinding sounds
Hey yeah!
This is definitely the first time I ever did this one
GA! @#%^^#@
FA!!!!!!!! #$@$
GET BACK!
NOOOO!!!!!!!!
NO!!!
I... We go
NO!!!!!!!!
And.. there we go.
NOOOOO!!!!!!
Alright
NO!!! Muna-(Gibberish) AH!!! AH!!
It's ok! Think of the Kittens! Think of the Kittens!
Just think of the Kittens! Keep the kittens in mind!
It's gonna be ok! Think of the kittens!
Think of the kittens!
Ok!
NO!!!!!!!! Whoa! Whoa!
Aren't you something?
AH!!!!!!
NO!!!!! FA! $#@